what do you think about Sears no longer  carrying whirlpool appliances okay I  don't know what either of those things  are yeah I don't really care I don't  shop at Sears  yes that's bad did you hear off Sears is  no longer carrying Whirlpool products  what hold on a second  hey honey are the kids with you it's  time I have to go  I am so sorry everyone but I made a vow  to your mother on our wedding day that  if Sears ever and I mean ever stop  selling whirlpool appliances this is  what I'd want I love you guys we love  you too  [Music]  so what do you think about Sears no  longer selling whirlpool appliances they  still make anymore  yeah yeah this does on oh yeah I'm fine  with that that I have a fridge I have a  dishwasher washing machine I like them I  never liked my head oh I just wash it  once to the little foam dishwasher  repairman was out every week with that  thing the other five but me  oh I'm a GE guy all the way all the way  hey I didn't go that way  you